h m under attack in China sticks to
stands with angered Beijing this is a
story from Wall Street Journal the chief
executive of h m Helena helmerson said
that the fashion giant wants to be
responsible buyers standing by a human
rights position that angered Beijing and
triggered the Brand's disappearance from
China's internet last week China's
leading e-commerce right hailing uh
daily deals and map applications removed
any reference to h m after statement at
issue last year about not sourcing
material from
xinjiang major cotton production region
in China suddenly went viral Alexander
Shapiro head of strategy at Beijing
branding agency PBB creative said h m
essentially has two choices it can keep
its head down and hope the boycott ends
quietly or it could stick by its human
rights stance risking sales indefinitely
it could also preemptively pull out a
move that could benefit the brand
outside China if it is seen as a as
willing to stand up to Beijing the
attention could have been more valued
than your Chinese business he said
thoughts
this is China China decides what the
people can see and China controls 100 of
their media
the question is the bigger question
really is are we becoming China that's
really the bigger question I mean this
this has been going on in China forever
China doesn't like something you don't
see it if you're a Chinese citizen they
control what all their citizens see this
is the nature of being under a
dictatorship that they have the question
is is that what we have here I mean you
got you got a company like they canceled
uh my pillow I mean what the hell is
that I mean this guy's just got an
opinion and all of a sudden now all
these stores are throwing his Merchant
they what they won't carry his
merchandise at Bed Bath and Beyond and
all these stores decide they're not
going to carry his stuff because he's a
conservative it's ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous and I don't really care what
happens in China we know this is not
news in China they do this all the time
the question is are we becoming China
do you actually think we're becoming
China uh we're taking steps in that
direction yes because we're Banning the
my pillow guy it's not just that cancel
culture is by the way have you ever used
a pillow I have not it's not that good
it's a pillow relax Adam yes forget
about canceling the my pillow again
we're canceling the president's
interview with his daughter I already
took a stance on that I don't agree with
that that's what China does if China
doesn't want something to be heard they
just shut it down okay so you guys have
been in America longer than I have I've
only been here since 1990. you've been
here your entire life you've been here
your entire life minus that one stent
when you went out of the country to
Addison Texas outside of that you've
been here greatest place on Earth we've
never seen anything like this okay
that's what I was gonna ask you've never
seen anything I've ever seen before
what's been the closest to today
anything has anything been coming was
Reagan ever silenced was Nick was Nixon
silenced like let's put a Nixon could
Nixon get on TV doing interview and they
would show it always
they've never silenced so what's worse
what Nixon did or what Trump did
which particularly the reputation the
reputation the way Nixon's career ended
versus the way Trump's career Ended as a
president as of right now okay the media
the way they sold the story to the
public okay the way the media sold the
story to the public versus what really
happened okay here's what Trump did he
is terrible he's a divisive guy he's
this he said okay Nixon Watergate you
know control doesn't let anybody in he
doesn't talk to anybody he's a Hermit
he's this he's that he's that it's hard
to compare those those are so different
the point I'm trying to make too is the
following the point I'm trying to make
too is the following
which one had more of an argument to say
he shouldn't get the platform to speak
on TV Nixon or Trump neither you can't
you can't ever say you don't get the
platform you can't say you can't speak
on TV this is what our country's all
exactly what I'm saying it's neither one
of them so the point the point I'm
trying to make to you is right now
today's era that we've had today for me
all I know is last 31 years I don't know
nothing past 31 years okay you go past
31 years could any president get on and
just give their speech and give their
thoughts a past present and say here's
what I think about what's going on was
there any time where anyone was silenced
no ever I can't remember
forget about 31 years we're talking
about the last six months so it's not
like Trump is silenced in 2020 he was
silenced since January of 2021 we're
talking three four months no no wait a
minute beginning it was fact-checked
yeah beginning anything he said no since
November since he lost the election no
no no he was he started anything he
would post saying watch them use this
against me from that moment on they
would always fetch him at the bottom
saying hey this is not so from October
he started getting pushed around by
social media by the way I have no
problem with fact checks by the way are
there is there such a thing on social
media as as does any of the social media
platforms Facebook Twitter and do they
employ any conservative fact Checkers is
there a single one
effect checking the left I don't know
what happened to say whatever the hell
job qualification uh situation you have
to be a lefty I don't think that's the I
think there are people that go into it
or left to stop I don't think that you
I'm a lefty I'm coming to work for
Google I don't think that's how it works
I think they they're looking for
qualified candidates you okay got it so
going back to it you've never seen
nothing like this before listen people
have boycotted okay companies for things
they don't like I remember uh I was
maybe 15 20 years ago they they were
going to play the Masters and since
since the uh Augusta National had no
women members there was a women's group
I can't remember who it was that that
headed it up and they said we're
boycotting we're boycotting you know
they were they were marching outside and
they what they did was they decided
we're going to try to get them to not
buy the products for from Cadillac or
IBM or those and then what the master
said was what Augusta nationalists said
was fine you don't want to buy I'll tell
you what we're not going to take any
advertising this year that way you don't
you can boycott all you want do whatever
and you know eventually it went away but
to to literally cancel someone say you
can't be you you can't be in our store I
mean corporations to start to start
pandering to to it's just Insanity well
speaking of uh hi Jen
we have appearance by Jennifer Bett
David yeah I mean this doesn't have
what's going on why don't you say hello
to everybody real quick come on camera
say hi we're how many weeks do we have
left babe how many weeks we got left
um so I'm 28 weeks on Saturday 12th
we got how you feeling you feeling good
bring it yes yeah yeah she's sitting
last night doing homework with the kids
we had to work with Tico yesterday on
how to write what he learns by the way
good story on what what I told Tico she
was there this was a hilarious story
yeah so I feel uncomfortable you
standing up babe but I'll tell the story
so so here's what happened yesterday
it's a funny story yeah so Tico has a
hard time reading and putting what he
read on paper he doesn't like to do that
he just likes to read give him a book he
reads through two three books you give
it to him he'll be done with it right
so he's reading the Jackie Kennedy book
and I say so what did you learn from the
book so he writes her Jackie Kennedy's
husband was a former senator
the next sentence is they lived in such
and such two sentences I'm like you got
to give me more than this I said let me
ask you a question do you ever want to
make movies he says yeah I said you're
going to write scripts with movies he
says of course I said when you write
scripts about a movie what Spielberg
when some of these guys would do is it's
all about details you got to give
details he says give me an example I
said let me write a script for you he
says what's that I said so one day this
boy walks out in a backyard when he goes
in the backyard he hears a noise and a
shadow it's dark he can't see anything
he opens the door to go to the backyard
all of a sudden here's something run to
the side so he looks to the right he's
wondering what it is as he walks closer
to the chair he sees a splash in the
water sees a shadow under the water
moving looks over there to see what it
is he hears the sound to the right again
I said that's what you got to do he says
continue with the story
so what happened
like the point I'm trying to make to he
said no no go continue
so he moves the chair come cockroach
jumps out so it's okay it's nothing
crazy then he gets closer to the pool he
looks over the water he sees the shadow
moving next thing you know someone
behind him pushes him in the pool then
when he falls in the pool it's dark he
sees this Shadow swing up to him guess
what it was what it was his dad playing
a prank on it oh what a great story that
I said now write it like that this was
yesterday with two days ago with Tico
but anyways thank you for this week and
FY so everybody knows is this coffee no
does your husband drink coffee no no
okay so does your husband need coffee no
not at all that's the real question
be mixed with hot milk and some a few
pumps of vanilla mixed with a it's
always comes with lipstick on it just so
you know mine always comes
she took a sip out of it sexy cup of tea
yeah
she's the canary in the coal mine yeah
she is can we give a quick shout out to
Jen for a second I don't know what
you're doing with your skin but like
you've it's incredible you're glowing
zero blemishes pregnancy is that what it
is that was my next time
see what happens to you I'll see what I
can do
well your skin looks ridic
ulous so awesome thank you baby thank
you okay so where were we nice little
appearance well let me cancel culture
okay I do we're right at uh the point
where they're they're um canceling
agents
you know what's the story with Augusta
that you were they they boycotted it but
boy the bottom line is I don't think
this is where the American people are I
don't think the American people like
cancel culture I don't think I'm liking
I don't like them canceling comedians
anything I mean a guy like Don Rickles
could not survive today
look at our friend Bill Burr he's
somehow making it out there very few but
there's an interesting YouTube video
about Bill bro we're talking about
yesterday how this one guy has analyzed
how he does it and how he comes to both
sides and he brings people in and when
he realizes that he stepped in due to he
he knows how to get out of it very
quickly by either self-deprecation or
something does something
the best it's the comedian defense Pat's
looking into that from what I understand
I won't mind doing it you have no idea
how much I'm looking forward to doing
one day I go 5-10 minutes at a local
Club here I show an appearance opening
and then if I like it I may do it once a
month who knows if I like it oh you're
gonna like it if I like it I may do it
because here's the good thing here's
what's gonna happen because you're gonna
do it and there's gonna be one of two
outcomes you're either gonna crush it
clearly because you're yeah awesome at
this and you're gonna get a taste of it
you're like I want to do that again or
you're gonna bomb
and you're gonna say I freaking can't go
out like that I gotta go back so
regardless yeah 100 so what are your
banking on the Obama or killing it crush
it I think you're gonna crush it and
you're gonna get a feel for damn this is
funny yeah and then here's the community
another thing to my list of things when
you when you because I did comedy for
many many years and then I got into
finance and you know I still and I
opened up a comedy club in South Beach
shout out to Bodega shout out to Ricky's
um
you can always say well I was joking I'm
a comedian like it's a great defense
guys don't take me seriously I'm joking
over here
um John Stewart got to win kind of like
Louise Lewis last Saturday Night Live
but last point just about h m is not you
know boycotting can you remember a few
years ago they came out with a shirt
that were all up in the news they they
had a little black kid cute little black
guy uh 10 year old kid and the shirt
ironically was coolest monkey in the
jungle do you remember this ridiculous
situation that they had oh you know what
I'm laughing at I'm laughing at the guy
saying Adam would cancel pbd on Twitter
if it got him an extra hundred thousand
followers Joseph Smith to cancel Joe
yeah go ahead so this was a big deal for
h m this is I think this happened maybe
20 years ago okay how ridiculous is that
cute little kid maybe six years old
coolest monkey in the jungle are you
flipping freaking kidding me so they had
to walk that back apologize all that so
ever since then they've definitely taken
a bit is this a spoof or is not a spoof
this is real life this is actually the
shirt this cannot be real this is real
and that was the model they used yes
try doing that today how would you what
year is this I'm actually I'm guessing
2018. I'm guessing and nothing happened
to them oh no no no no backlash boycott
all that so obviously in the last two or
three years they said holy [ __ ] we gotta
clean up our act a little bit is that
ridiculous or no that's you didn't know
about this story well let me tell you
whoever was the CMO the market or ought
to be fired oh they were if if you have
half a brain you ought to know that just
makes no sense right there ridiculous
yeah um so what was your what was your
answer what's my point so obviously h m
had to kind of get woke whoa and they
had to basically start taking stances on
things like China because this whole
story started with basically they're
speaking up against human rights in
China which obviously I totally agree
with Byron you know you either play ball
with China
STFU shut up and get or get out of the
way lose your fund and get canceled and
potentially disappear like our friend
Jack ma but the the the the bigger
question here with China and H M is
you ever shop at h m
maybe once my favorite store to shop at
are you kidding me no it's your favorite
store that's the best deal in the game
anyone who needs new clothes and they're
like well I'm not sure where to go
because I'm all about to save that money
h m is ready you can go there and spend
300 bucks and have an entire new
wardrobe
it's amazing so shout out to h m just
don't get those sweaters with the
coolest monkeys what percentage of the
population do you think is if they had
to vote thumbs up or thumbs down on
where the country's going in terms of
wokeness and being for more wokeness or
less wokeness where do you think the
country you think the country's like
yeah we got to get more woke or the
country is
most people like this is such a bunch of
crap
the majority of people are are not in
the woke Camp is what I'm assuming in
the world camp or do they agree with it
I think they need they need to learn
cancel culture is is a fad and it will
be
phased out you know as as all this stuff
but don't forget
don't forget Byron when you were 20
years old you were voting for freaking
Jimmy Carter you were a hippie you were
smoking grass whatever you were doing
now you're conservative smoking weed but
go ahead I said grass yeah
um so things change over time so
what is politically correct changes over
over time in the 1960s what was
politically correct was to hate the war
be against the war March against the war
he turned out to be the freaking right I
understand peace love but our veterans
came back and they were treated
just it was embarrassing they were
embarrassing I think it's horrible
unbelievable so embarrassing it almost
makes me want to cry I mean it is so
embarrassing the way we treated our
veterans and that's what was politically
correct and it's just it and it's in it
nowadays you thank them for their
service even Vietnam Vets you go back
and say you know my God you really you
went a lot of people didn't go they went
to Canada they got some sort of bone
spur or whatever everybody's got an
excuse my point is that political
correctness changes it's there's nothing
there's no immutable truth and they act
like oh my God this that's you can't say
that you can't do that you you do that
you're going to get canceled you need to
do you do get canceled people worry
about being canceled people worry about
mistakes they've made I don't believe
that when people make mistakes they
should not be able to earn a living I
think they should pay the price for
their mistakes and they should be able
to earn a living I don't think you
should cancel a comedian I mean I don't
think he should cancel Louis CK for
whatever he did I don't think he should
cancel Kevin Spacey for what he did if
he'd committed a crime let him pay the
price for the crime but he's a great
actor let him act I mean he's good at
what he does I don't I I just don't
think it's fair to cancel people's
ability to support their families and do
what they do just to make your point
Who's Who the question is
who's making those decisions of being
afraid to you know sit there and say
yeah let's go ahead and shut down let's
go ahead and cancel this thing here
because we're going to get so much
backlash that's that's who the problem
is the problem is who's caving in
that who's caving that's the problem the
problem is the problem isn't complaining
that's been going around for thousands
of years right the problem is a kid
comes complaining to Dad and says you
won't realize what the other one did oh
my gosh what do they do are you kidding
me the teacher said this let me call the
teacher right now they will never talk
to my son like this ever again like
hypothetically right right so it's the
parents that's the fault not the
complainer I think the complainer is
never going to go
we have been conditioned to become
offended by just about everything and
it's just annoying as hell the only
thing that offends me really truly
offends me or upsets me about is when
someone gets offended or upset or
triggered about something that's not
worth getting triggered about it that's
that's what offends me like what do you
get over it give me a break I mean you
see all these sports teams changing
their names they're caving to
cancel culture if you will I mean the
Washington Redskins
I mean you heard what happened of course
you find you know finally WFT fin
finally after after all these years uh
you know you what's with Dan Snyder I
think his name is he finally did you
hear a speech when he changed when he
decided he said yeah you know I after
all these years I've been hearing on
pressure and pressure and pressure we
don't want to you know we don't want to
offend anybody anymore so moving forward
starting Monday
the Washington Redskins are now just
going to be known as
the Redskins
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]